Hey, Matt, it's Bread Week,
and as a special treat
for the viewers, I've brought
in my mate Roger Crust.
He's a loaf of bread
but he can actually talk.
Noel, don't be ridiculous.
Bread can't talk.
That's what I thought
but check this guy out.
Say "hello" to Matt.
Noel, I will tolerate your whimsy
to a point
but we do have a show to host.
Oh, what's that about?
Why didn't you say hello?
Sorry, I got a bit shy.
Bit shy?
Well, I've never seen
a celebrity before.
What about me?
Can I still say welcome to
The Great British Bake Off?
Yeah, all right.
Sorry I got shy again.
Welcome to The Great British
Bake Off.
...Off. There I did the end bit.
Roger Crust!
Last time...
Kakow!
...the bakers battled biscuits...
Oh, this is so stressful.
Why did I make it so thin? Right.
...and while Maxy's
magnificent mask...
I think it looks totally amazing.
...won her a first Star Baker...
GASPS
Oh.
...Carole's cookie crumbled.
It's fallen.
But it was Maisam's mask
that slipped...
I'd have liked you to do just
a little bit more. Maisam.
...and she became the latest baker
to leave the competition.
This is definitely not
the end of my baking journey.
This time...
Oh, my God, OK.
...the bakers are on Paul's patch.
I'm trying to get 'em in the proving
drawer before he gets over here.
Bread...
Panic. Ah!
They must impress
with perfect pizzas...
Oh. Forgot my mozzarella.
Tackle a classic
French patisserie...
I'm just getting rid all of
the feelings I've got.
...and recreate a Swedish
celebration cake.
This is Tomorrow's World.
What's happening?
Who will be partying?
I was born in Sweden.
OK. So you know what you're doing.
I've got an idea.
And who will be left
with that sinking feeling?
Didn't see this coming.
Bread week, challenging week.
Paul's favourite.
Good luck to everyone.
After last week's escapade I did
lose a little bit of confidence
but then I've got my lucky big pants
on now!
My apple catchers!
So, ready for anything today.
I think it was my flavour choices
that got me where I was last week
and I just hope they like
these ones.
I'm scared stiff
about my bread decision.
It will either pay off
or it'll be catastrophic.
Good morning bakers,
welcome back to the tent.
Now, both Rebs and Abdul are a bit
under the weather this week but,
uh, with your permission we thought
we'd send them both straight through
to the final. I hope that's OK.
THEY LAUGH
Only joking!
They're just going to miss a week.
Hopefully they'll be
back next week.
Now for your Signature Challenge
the judges would love you
to make two sharing sized pizzas
that need to be delicious.
They should be the kind
of pizzas that make Paul
and Prue say "Mamma Mia!"
or the title of any other film
starring Pierce Brosnan.
You can take inspiration
from anywhere around the world.
Goldeneye.
Good luck, bakers.
The Thomas Crown Affair!
You have two hours.
On your marks.
Get set.
Mrs Doubtfire!
I mean, he wasn't even starring
in that film.
No, but he was in it.
Pierce Brosnan played the new
boyfriend of the woman that...
Shall we go and watch it?
Yeah, let's go and watch it.
All right, bye-bye.
Bake!
THEY LAUGH
I've made pizza more than once,
less than ten.
Pizza, seems simple, doesn't it?
Bit of sourdough starter.
Bit of yeast.
A little bit of beetroot juice.
Two hours is not
a huge amount of time.
I would spend most of that
preparing the dough.
The dough's got to be
a little bit wetter than normal.
So, you get those sort of bubbles
and these tend to scorch on
the top which I love.
I'm very much a firm believer
of pineapple does belong
on a pizza.
That's, like, controversy that, innit?
Overload with too many
fillings will cause problems to
the base cos it won't be able
to bake properly.
So, good strong flavours,
not too many of them.
What we're looking
for is golden brown on the outside,
punching with flavour.
Look at this,
it didn't really blend well.
And we need two, ideally identical.
Ooh, I'm just going to start again.
I hope I have enough
sourdough starter.
James, morning.
Hello, James. Good morning.
Tell us all about your pizza.
So, I went for
the controversial option.
I went for a ham
and pineapple pizza.
I've tried to upscale it
a wee bit, so using pancetta.
I think you're very brave James.
I mean we might have been one of
the many people who think that
it's a crime to put pineapple
on pizza. Are you?
Uh, how did you know we might.
Why is that?
I don't know.
When you're a kid you love the idea
of a Hawaiian pizzarette thing.
Yeah, exactly.
It's blows your little mind.
James certainly hopes
that his grilled pineapple
and pancetta take on the classic Hawaiian
will blow Paul and Prue's minds.
But his choice of dough
might cause a bigger stir.
I had some strong bread flour
and I've also balanced it
with about, I think, 14%,
spelt flour. Why?
It just gives it like a slight sort
of nutty flavour. Really?
14% gives you a nutty flavour?
This is wild. You're talking nuts,
you're talking pineapple.
You're talking ham. Put some
toothpaste in there, I'm in.
Good luck James.
Cheers, thank you.
Is 14 too much spelt flour?
Is it too little? I have no idea.
Whatever flour the bakers use,
of equal importance is kneading
their dough until it's smooth
and stretchy,
to achieve the texture
the judges will be expecting.
I'm kneading.
Where did you see this technique?
In a book.
That wasn't from mine!
No.
I do it slightly different.
Care to elaborate?
No.
I actually learnt from my food tech
teacher in Year seven.
Don't know if it's
the right technique?
There's actually four of you doing
the same technique.
Really?
Yeah.
If he's not going to tell us, then
I just need to crack on,
do it my way and see what he's got
to say about it.
The practice went really well.
My family loved it.
I only got a tiny slice for myself.
Maxy will be hoping for a repeat
performance with the judges.
Last week's Star Baker has drawn
inspiration from her
favourite roast,
topping the pizza with lamb
and flavouring the dough
with rosemary.
I'm looking forward to that lamb.
Should be interesting.
How is it being Star Baker?
I still can't believe it!
I'm so happy!
You've got stars on, haven't you?
It's for you. Oh, thank you.
It's a little tribute.
Thank you, Maxy.
Thank you. Good luck. Sounds lovely.
Thank you.
I just hope I live up to the
expectations that they've got now.
When they're happy
with its consistency
the bakers need to cover
their dough...
If you use shower caps
it's just sort of reusable.
I always nick them from hotels,
so if you ever have any just pass
them on to me, please.
...and rest it in the proving drawer.
Off you go.
It needs to double in size
and then we know that it's ready.
But one baker still hasn't got
a dough to prove...
I abandoned my plan
with the beetroot juice.
It didn't foam up really well.
Having abandoned her first dough,
Syabira is making a second.
We wasted 20 minutes
just to figure out this dough.
I'm just going to put this onion
and start grinding
and make my sambal.
Syabira's spicy Malaysian prawn
sambal paste will provide the base
for her pizzas which will be topped
with prawns, anchovies,
and another South East Asian
speciality, the stinky bean.
I don't know if it's appropriate
to say.
Usually it stinks
when you have a wee. Ha!
So you're feeding Paul Hollywood
something that's going to make
his wee-wee smell?
Yeah, that's how you mark
your territory.
That's why I love this lady.
While Syabira finishes prepping
her dough...
Ah, this is nightmare.
...most of the other bakers
are making headway...
Creme fraiche, cream cheese,
egg yolk.
...with the sauces that will add
flavour and moisture
to their pizzas...
I decided to make my own tomato
sauce from scratch instead
of actually using passata.
...and while most have gone
for savoury flavours...
It'll take about 40 minutes or so
to reduce right down to a thick jam.
...Kevin's hoping to hit
the sweet spot.
I can't get behind
the idea of pineapple on pizza
but I thought I'd try another
kind of fruit.
This recipe's called
"Now Bring Us Some Figgy Pizza."
Kevin's hoping to balance his sweet
chilli jam and balsamic glaze
with salty halloumi
and fresh rocket.
And the figs?
The figs I've just chopped
into little chunks
to scatter over the top.
Interesting.
Good luck. Look forward to trying
it. Thank you. Thank you.
Looks delicious. Good luck.
Figs had the Prue approval.
A-Prue-val...
Kevin's is the only
vegetarian pizza.
Yeah, I just need to let this boil
and boil and boil and boil
and boil and boil and boil.
While he can relax
until he's ready to bake...
Some black pudding.
There is lots to do.
...the other bakers have additional
elements to cook.
Lamb's my favourite meat.
If I had long enough time
I would've made roasted lamb.
But Dawn's not letting
the brevity of the challenge
interfere with her preferred cut.
It's a beef stewing steak.
It's a relatively cheap cut
of beef, actually,
but it's lovely,
if you can give it a long cook.
So, I've cut it quite small in
the hopes that I can get it
to get reasonably tender in time.
I'm a little bit nervous about that
but we'll see.
Before baking Dawn till top her
pizza with mozzarella
and fresh chillies,
and for added Tex Mex appeal
she'll garnish
with sour cream and guacamole.
We've had it for dinner twice
at home.
I made two sharing size pizzas
and two of us didn't share.
We just ate the whole lot!
And she's not the only baker
looking stateside for inspiration...
You can't beat a Texas smoky
barbecue rub - you can't beat that.
Americans do barbecue the best.
I'm going to get the peppers chopped
up and my pineapple of course, yeah.
Not only is Sandro combining
tropical fruits
with the taste of the USA,
he's topping with Spanish chorizo
and filling the crust with
a little flavour of France.
So I'm stuffing it
with Camembert and honey.
Good, I love a stuffed crust.
And I'm making it heart-shaped
just to add some love to it.
Good luck, Sandro.
Thank you.
That smells so good.
Can you do the judging?
Yeah.
Yeah?
Bakers, you are halfway through!
It's rising.
Imagine that.
Well, they don't have to imagine it
because they are halfway through.
Sometimes it helps to imagine
things... Yeah, but why...
...just before they happen.
But you said it after. Oh, yeah.
My bread seems to not be rising,
which is a little bit alarming
because it's never happened before!
HE LAUGHS
We just keep it in there
until I'm ready to roll a minute.
I'm going to try
and get a second bread dough going.
Hopefully that'll be ready in time.
What are you doing?
Cutting up some reblochon.
What's that?
It's a cheese that you don't like.
I don't like any cheese.
What else is going in it?
More cheese.
Oh! Which one?
Some gruyere.
You're making these up. No, I'm not.
Carole's Gruyere
and reblochon cheeses
will be combined
with pancetta,
potatoes and onions
to recreate
the classic French
dish tartiflette.
So, you're putting tartiflette on
a pizza? That's not unusual.
Where did you have this?
We used to move boats from
the UK down to the Med. Right.
Used to have to eat pizza
cos it was quick and on the go,
and this is one
of my favourite ones.
OK, so that makes sense.
Good luck. Thank you. Thank you.
When it comes to combining
national dishes with her pizzas
Carole is in good company.
I just think the combination works
really well
and it's a different approach
towards pizza.
Good morning, good morning.
Good morning, Janusz.
We want to know all about
your pizza.
I'm doing full English breakfast
on pizza.
There's going to be some
black pudding,
there's going to be sausage,
there's going to be bacon.
Mushroom and baked beans.
Oh!
I was feeling happy until you said
baked beans.
To complete his full English
Janusz is adding Cheddar
and mozzarella,
and in the middle he'll crack an egg
a few minutes before removing
the pizzas from the oven.
I'm not really concerned
and I'm hoping they're going
to like the flavours.
Right, it's risen, which is good.
Are you on schedule? I think so I'm
about to shape the dough.
Then I'm going to throw my
toppings on and bake. Go on, then.
Yeah.
Go on, then. Go on, then!
The second batch, it's not proved
enough yet, either way.
So, I think let's go for batch one.
Usually it's a wee bit kind of
puffed up and crispy
but I think it's just going
to be crispy!
They've got a little bit of
a hole going on.
Put potato over it.
The beef is not as tender as
I wanted it to be. It's too chewy.
How long do we have?
You have half an hour left
to make your pizzas!
I can't delay more.
Basically, if it's going wrong
you've still got time to order one.
As my English teacher used
to say that is a symbolic downpour.
I'm going to bake one at a time.
I've tried at home baking couple
at a time
and they don't bake as well as one.
Dawn, Sandro and James...
Bake, baby, bake.
...Are also using this strategy.
I'm using the stone because I think
you get much better result.
Everyone else is baking both their
pizzas at the same time.
Think these are a well bit well cut
and all stuck together.
Nothing can compare
with stinky bean smell.
I don't know how to describe it.
It's just stinky.
Right, ready, steady.
I'm going to set my timer for ten
and then have a look
and see how they're doing.
220, ten to 12 minutes.
Oh, come on.
Normally, when I put them in
they kind of go "puff"
and they're done really quickly.
Not going to jinx it -
the crust is puffing up slightly!
I never knew pizza dough
could be so stressful.
Egg is going in. Don't let me down.
And this is a typical breakfast
for you?
This is a Sunday breakfast
when you went out on Saturday.
Would you go to Revenge
in Brighton? I prefer Legends.
Oh, you prefer Legends, right, OK.
I can see that you've been there!
Well, I'm familiar with the concept.
Oh! Glasses.
That's looking good, innit?
Yeah, not bad.
See, spelt flour,
it's the way forward.
That's how you do it, Mr Hollywood.
It's got a lot of grease
but I'll say it's baked.
Oh, no. Bit oily.
How does one ungrease a pizza?
Same way I ungrease my forehead.
Oh, I see.
With a little bit of a dabbing.
How long have we got left?
You have 15 minutes remaining!
It was going so well.
Kevin, I've put too much cheese
on mine. No such thing.
Well, I know that but it might be
in Mr Hollywood's eyes.
It's just a sea of cheese.
Great!
A bit soft underneath.
I'm going to give it another five.
I'll swap them over as well.
The oven must be a bit uneven.
Oh, forgot my mozzarella!
Oops! I knew there
was something missing.
I'm just going to sit here
and watch them.
It's a bit different in size.
One, two, three.
No.
Oh, my God! OK.
Ooh! Sorry!
Bakers,
you have one minute remaining.
Nope.
There's just so much oil
in the middle.
Egg is runny.
Stick some figs on and then some
drizzle some balsamic glaze.
I think it's a winner.
I'm going to do it 30 seconds
and then blowtorch the egg,
what can you do?
Oops!
20 more seconds. 19, 18...
It's hot but let's make it hotter, eh?
16, 15...
Bottom is cooked.
It's just cooked.
Bakers, your time is up!
Please step away from your pizzas.
I think the egg yolk will be runny.
It should be excellent.
I think I've overdid it again.
The bakers will now have their
pizzas judged by Prue and Paul.
Hello, Syabira.
Hello. Hi, Syabira.
This is my sourdough
and yeast dough pizza base.
It looks great. I like the walls
that you've managed to build
and I like the way you've kept it
all inside.
It looks very neat.
Good base on it - crispy.
I have anchovies,
dried shrimps and chilli.
Can't get all the flavours?
Except the chilli.
It's slightly overwhelmed
by the chilli.
But, nevertheless,
it's a great structure inside.
Thank you.
Yeah, well done.
I think you've slightly overdone
the base.
It is very dark.
Love your whole pizza
parlour table.
It's still runny.
It's still a bit, runny great.
I can't take him anywhere. Honestly!
There's so much in there.
The crust is lovely and thin.
Thank you.
Weirdly, I'm not getting like huge
amounts of flavour from it.
It needs to be a little bit
more punchy. Thank you.
Well done.
It's very pretty. Yeah.
That base looks quite nice.
Going to be fascinating
to see what it tastes like.
I like the colour.
Yeah. Your dough looks a bit dead.
The chilli on the bottom works
beautifully well
with the balsamic and then
that little hint of fig.
I just think some of it's too sweet.
OK. Well done.
The base looks all right.
You've got a bit of life in there.
The shape is awful.
Yeah. This one's all over the place.
Love the colours on the top, though.
Nice texture on the crumb
on the end. Thank you.
You promised us an upscale version
of ham and pineapple.
I think you've done it.
Thank you!
I just think it's a little bit too
dry. You need more tomato.
Fair dos, thank you.
Probably could've had a little bit
more water to your dough. OK.
Just to allow a bit of fluffiness
to it cos there's no rise.
Surprisingly bland.
OK...
Was that beef mince?
It's not mince.
It's, uh, stewing beef.
Mince would've been better. Yeah.
That would've given you more
of a punch.
I think you've chosen
the wrong meat.
The chilli is strong.
I'm disappointed. Never mind.
There's lots more time.
Quite a thick base, isn't it?
Yeah.
It's a little bit more like
an American pizza.
Mm! Flavour is fantastic.
Thank you.
It's quite rich, that lamb,
you've got a great blend
of seasoning. It's delicious.
The only issue, for me,
is I think that base is too thick.
It does need to be a little bit
thinner. Thank you. Thank you.
It's a great shape.
It really looks so inviting,
doesn't it? Yeah, it does.
Thank you, darling.
This is really messy pizza.
Yes, it is!
I think your barbecue flavours
inside with the pineapple
and the Camembert
running all the way through
cos it carries such a nice flavour.
Pleased with that.
It's ingenious. You have got quite
a lot of different flavours there,
but they're still separate,
aren't they?
I'd have one of them if I was
in a pizzeria.
Oh. Yeah.
That's great. Well done.
You put too much of it on because
it's spewing out all over the place.
Can't really see the pizza at all. Hmm.
Little on this is better
than a lot. OK.
You've layered on so much
that that's basically what's
happened to the base. Hmm.
It should be holding.
Mm-hm.
Tastes divine.
It's absolutely beautiful.
So, you only made one mistake -
too much of a good thing!
Thank you.
Thank you. Well done.
Your worst nightmare.
I didn't even look at it.
I just looked at you!
Who doesn't want too much topping
on their pizza?
Usually, it's not enough topping.
It was bad. It was bad.
Oh!
I didn't get a handshake
but I think I was almost there.
I am glowing. Probably the
foundation on my skin but, yeah,
I'm very happy. I'm super happy.
The bakers were able to practice
for the first challenge
but the next one is a mystery.
Bakers, it's time
for your Technical Challenge.
Which today has been set by
the priest of yeast,
Paul Hollywood.
You have to be fast
and accurate with this recipe.
Mm-hm. Amen.
OK, as ever this challenge
will be judged blind
so we're going to have to ask these
two poppets to exit the tent.
For your Technical Challenge
Paul would like you each to make
a dozen identical pain aux raisins.
Your pain aux raisins must be evenly
filled with raisins
and a smooth creme pat.
Each pain aux raisins should have
a crispy flaky laminated dough
and should be rolled to a perfect
swirl which keeps its shape.
One more thing -
Paul has specifically said
he doesn't want tails.
You have two hours and 45 minutes.
Seems ample.
Oh, it seems like plenty of time.
On your marks...
Get set... Bake!
I think I have an idea
of what we're making.
Bread with raisins.
That is quite a challenging one I
must admit.
So, Paul pain aux raisins -
that's not bread.
Basically, it's an enriched dough
when you think about it... Yeah.
...with butter folded through it.
They've got to make a dough,
knock out your butter,
place it onto two thirds of the
dough, fold over the exposed bit,
fold it up and that is, basically,
one turn.
You have to repeat that process
of folding another three times.
But they roll it out again
a bit more?
Yeah, they need to pop that
into a fridge,
cos if they don't all
the butter just falls out
and it's as dry as a bone.
We did mention the tails.
As you roll up the pain aux raisins,
you're left with
a little bit at the end.
If the pain aux raisins is not
proved enough it'll pop the end out.
And it's called a little tail.
We don't want that.
Let's try a pain aux raisins.
Perfect texture, isn't it?
Hmm! I'd forgotten how good
these are. Just so divine.
Can I have another cup of tea?
Make a dough...
...using 25g of the butter.
Which is very open
to interpretation.
I think I'm going to melt
the butter so that there's
a bit of warmth to get
the yeast activated.
Um, oh, wait no.
It says place it in the freezer.
This is an enriched dough.
So, it's along a similar line
to a brioche kind of bread...
An egg.
...so it just requires
a bit of attention.
I think there probably is
a technique
but at the moment I'm just bunging
it all together.
I'm really not sure.
Say hello to someone that you love.
Hello, Brad. That's my boyfriend.
What's he look like?
He got no hair.
He wears the spectacles. Glasses.
Is he on the "Guess Who" board?
It's actually pretty much done.
Going to place it in the freezer.
Just for five minutes.
With the remaining butter
we're going to make a rectangle
to go in to the dough.
I'm just getting rid all of
the feelings I've got.
To give the pain aux raisins
their flaky texture,
the bakers must fold butter
into the dough
in a process called lamination.
Roll the dough three more times,
chilling between each one.
If the dough gets warm, the butter
could leak out during baking...
Roll and chill, roll and chill.
...resulting in dry, tough pastries.
The butter has torn
underneath the pastry
so it means pastry's going to touch pastry,
but I've gone and done it now!
How did it go?
Did you get a handshake?
No, I didn't.
What did Prue say?
She said it was bland.
That's fighting talk. I know.
Do you reckon you could take Prue
in a fight? Course I could.
I'll handle Paul -
don't worry about that.
Ah, that's a deal. So, we're sort of
almost a wrestling partnership.
We are, aren't we, like a tag team?
Can't wait,
I'll go and order some trunks?
This is my last fold.
So, back for chilling.
Very helpful.
It says, "Make the creme pat."
It's like a French custard.
It's egg yolks and sugar and milk,
and cornflour, basically.
The key to a perfect creme pat which
I often struggle with is patience.
Don't be scared of it -
treat it with absolute contempt.
Creme patissiere I can make
with my eyes shut.
Creme pat should be smooth
and creamy.
This is the right consistency.
If it's too thin
it'll make the dough soggy.
I thought it would firm up.
Didn't see this coming.
And now it needs to go to
the fridge as soon as possible.
It takes a long time to cool.
So, they're halfway through
and it's a two hour 45 challenge.
I can't really do the maths.
I can do the maths.
OK, you go for it. OK.
Bakers,
you have eleventy five minutes left!
You're halfway through.
Ah!
Last roll.
So, now I need to roll it to
30 times 40.
Did you get those guns
from doing this? Yeah.
See, kids, if you roll pastry enough
you can have guns like that.
Like that.
Look at that.
I know.
Slightly smaller than mine.
Spread the cream patisserie
over the dough.
Sprinkle the raisins
and orange zest over the creme pat.
Roll into a sausage.
Now we're rolling up
really tightly.
It's gonna be a big sausage.
Just going to divide them into 12.
Problem is trying
to get them all the same size.
30 divided by 12?
If I do three centimetres.
That was a bit wobbly.
Oh, dear.
They are quite gooey.
Very wet.
The creme pat didn't quite
work out.
I'm pinching my tails
because Paul Hollywood
doesn't like a tail.
Well, that's your tail there,
so you tuck it in underneath.
Hopefully it'll keep it
where it's meant to be.
How much time have we got left now?
Bakers, you've got an hour left.
I mean, what you do with
the hour is up to you,
I'd do some baking,
but, obviously, it's up to you.
Prove is the one that worries me
cos how long do you prove it for?
I'm going to prove them
for around 25 minute.
If the pain aux raisins are
underproved they won't develop
the flaky texture
the judges expect.
I will just prove them until
I think it looks fine and ready.
They do need to put on some puff.
I haven't even bothered putting
them in a proving bag.
They're not going to dry out.
They're covered in a layer
of liquid creme pat anyway.
Who knows how they're going to end
up? This is uncharted territory.
I feel like patience is
the name of the game right now.
They are getting bigger now
so I'm quite, quite happy.
So what would you normally
be doing of an afternoon? Napping.
Yeah. Know where I sleep the best?
Where?
In the theatre.
What was that one that was about
Boy George?
Taboo.
I was in the original cast of it.
Oh, maybe it was...
Might have seen me. Oh, made an
impression didn't I, on that?
Cringe.
Ooh! Seems like this thing
has gone really hard
and the butter leak out.
Oh, stressing me out now!
They haven't puffed up as much as
I thought they would
but I don't know how much they're
meant to puff up.
Egg wash and bake.
Come on, boys!
They probably have to go in
for about 12, 15 minutes or so.
Until they are golden brown
and beautiful.
The thing I should've put them
on two trays
cos when they grow they're going to
bump into each other.
Schoolboy error.
Start the timer.
I'm going to go ten minutes
to start.
They're looking pretty decent,
I hope.
I think they're looking OK-ish.
I've got a nice view of all the
butter weeping straight out of it.
No, this is grim viewing.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left!
OK.
They look all right.
They smell good.
I see lamination for the nation.
OK, so those are definitely ready.
It doesn't look like what
I've seen in the supermarket!
Almost had one of those moments.
Oh, dear that's a bad one.
Big tail.
On the sides they've not cooked
very evenly - yet another issue.
They're only just touching.
Make the icing and drizzle
over the cooled pain aux raisins.
Fan power.
How long we got left, guys?
Bakers, you have one minute left!
Panic! Oww!
It's a bit runny, this icing.
It's a dollop in the middle
and it does its thing.
Oh, dear, that's not very neat.
Is it too hot?
Oh, I hope I've got enough icing.
This is a good one -
that stays up front.
I wish my sizes were more
equal but...
They are what they are.
Bakers, your time is up!
Well done matey.
Elbow!
Please bring your pain aux raisins
down to the front
and place them behind
your photograph.
How did you get them so round?
How you did that I have no idea -
that's not fair.
I hate technicals.
Prue and Paul are looking for 12
flaky pain aux raisins
filled with a smooth creme patisserie
and they have no idea
whose are whose.
Now, these are quite flat.
That looks as if
the butter ran out of it.
The butter did run out of it.
The flavours are all right
but it is quite doughy.
A similar thing with this one.
They're square, got too many on a
tray, so they've joined together.
It's lost quite
a bit of butter, as well.
There's a bit too much icing
for me.
Yeah. Too packed together.
Moving on,
I quite like the look of these.
Yeah, nice and golden.
High, quite wide. No tails.
You have a flake.
Good flavour.
Very good.
Moving on...
If I was in a shop, would you have
that one or that one?
Yes.
"Same price, sir."
Flavour's OK but so irregular.
These are all regular.
Some of them have sprung a little.
Yeah. Bit small again.
Needed to be a bit bigger
than this. Not quite risen enough.
Nice flake.
Flavour's good - just needed another
ten, 15 minutes proving.
Moving on. They are too small.
Underproved again
but flavour's good.
Very good orangey flavour.
I love that.
I quite like the look of these.
Yeah, some of them.
I'd feel a little cheated
if I got that one.
Hmm.
Actually, that's really nice.
It's not bad, its lamination's all
right. Flavour?
Lovely flavour, lots of orange.
Yeah.
These are...
Every one's got a tail.
They've definitely sprung.
It's well risen.
It's lost a bit of butter there,
can you see?
How dry it is down there.
The flavour's quite nice.
But the tail's a little bit ugly.
And, also, that's too much icing.
The pains aux raisins will now
be ranked from last to first place.
In eighth place, we have this one.
Carole, they're the wrong shape,
aren't they?
Because you had too many on the tray
and so they stuck together.
It's much too much icing
and underbaked.
In seventh, we have this one.
Underproved, you just didn't allow
them to grow. They're very skinny.
Dawn is sixth, Syabira is fifth,
Sandra is fourth,
and James is third.
Right, well, now we're getting into
the really good ones.
Um, who is this? This is number two.
Maxy, they tasted lovely
and they're very nice and tall.
One or two of them could have been
a little bit bigger.
Thank you.
But in first, we have these.
You had beautiful colour,
great flake and great flavour.
Well done.
My God!
I just cannot believe I got
the first in Technical
on the Bread Week because bread is
wild, it has a mind of its own.
Yours were really good.
I was so worried about my little buttons
but they got me a second place
so I'm quite proud of them.
Little bit of a disappointment.
But it was my fault.
That went better than I thought.
Second last rather than last.
Just one challenge remains
before Prue and Paul
decide who will be this
week's Star Baker
and who will be leaving
the competition.
Good morning, bakers,
welcome back to the tent
for your showstopper challenge.
Now, today, the judges
would like you
to create your own interpretation of
the Swedish smorgastarta.
Can you say that word again?
I've never heard it before.
Sure, Swedish.
A smorgastarta is Swedish
for sandwich cake.
The judges are looking for
an incredible savoury
celebration cake
made up of layers of sliced bread
with delicious fillings
and topped with exquisite
savoury decorations.
You have four and a half hours.
On your marks...
Get set...
Bake!
I had never heard of a smorgastarta.
Trying to search them, I was like
I'm not sure that these actually exist.
I think they've just made it up.
Gone to Sweden quite a bit,
but I've never had one of these.
Smorgastarta, it's going to be interesting
how people say it, isn't it?
Smorgasarte, smurgest... urgh.
Smorgastarta...
"Smorgas" - Swedish for sandwich,
torta, cake. Sandwich cake.
So you've got bread layers with
savoury fillings all the way down.
A savoury outside
and a beautiful decoration on
the top.
So I look at my list, it's just
a lot of things to make.
I'm nervous of some of our bakers
going a bit over the top.
I'm going to have three different fillings.
Sausages and a lot of cheese.
If you have fillings that are too wet,
it's going to soak into the bread
and then you'll get just
a sodden mess.
That's what exactly I did
for my practice.
You want it consistent with
a beautiful all-round flavour.
There's too much in it.
Must look like a cake
and taste like a sandwich.
It's the beast. Argh!
Hello, Carole. Hello, Carole. Morning.
Tell us all about
your smorgastarta.
I've been to Sweden quite
a few times now
cos we've got some friends over there.
And I'm doing a fish one
because if you go in one of
the supermarkets over there,
it is all fish.
Mackerel and salmon take
centre stage
in Carole's smorgastarta,
along with pickled cucumber and egg
sandwiched between white
seeded bread.
Can you tell us about the dough
itself? Can you tell me the flour?
Uh, one kilo of flour.
How much liquid? 750.
That's not the recipe that you've
just told me.
Go on. It's too dry.
Probably down to the amount of flour
you've got on the bench.
I'm going to get some more water.
Good luck, Carole.
He's a Prince of the East,
isn't he?
I was getting all, like, flustered
talking to him.
A dependable bread is
the foundation
upon which every great smorgastarta
is built.
I'm just making
a plain old white bread
cos it's the easiest thing to do.
Can't go wrong.
But that's not stopped some bakers
being a bit out there with their
flour choices.
I'm using emmer flour.
I only discovered it
a couple of days ago.
I wanted to get that kind
of Greek,
slightly nuttier sort of flavour
to the bread
and I'm using an ancient type
of wheat
that my friend's son grows.
Inspired by her holidays
to Greece,
Dawn's nutty wholewheat bread will
be stuffed
with olives and feta
and sandwich pulled chicken souvlaki
and tzatziki.
Are you using coriander in this?
I have not got coriander in it. No.
Unusual. I'll tell you,
I don't like it.
Coriander's in everything
and sesame seed?
I know. I know. No, I haven't put
any sesame in there.
No sesame either. OK.
So it's the flavours that I like.
Good luck, look forward to this.
Thank you.
When they're happy
with its texture...
It sort of springs back.
...the bakers need to get
the dough proving...
Yes!
...and crack on with
the cooked elements...
This is fool-proof recipe.
...that will fill their
sandwich cakes.
I don't know why they trusted me
with a deep fat fryer.
I wouldn't have allowed you
to have that.
Yeah, I said, "Guys, no.
Me and deep fat fryer - come on!"
I feel like, at the end of the day,
I'm going to walk off over there
and I look behind me
and the tent'll be in flames.
If there are flames,
you know who caused them.
Fiery curry sauce will cover
Janusz's showstopper
and it'll be filled with
fried cod and mayo,
crispy chips and mushy peas in
homage to his favourite post-pub
meal.
I honestly think it sounds
completely mad
and if you can pull it off,
I'll be so impressed.
Well, I must be mad.
Anyway, good luck with it.
Thank you.
Fish and chips is
a peculiar British thing,
especially with vinegar
and everything, yeah.
Which is really good.
But Janusz is not
the only baker reimagining
a national staple through
their smorgastarta.
So nasi lemak is one
of Malaysian favourites to go for,
I am actually trying to mimic
the kick of ginger
and a bit of, um, the taste of the
coconut in this mousse.
Inside Syabira's nasi
lemak-flavoured smorgastarta
will be another Malaysian speciality.
Roasted chicken in
a spicy sambal paste
sandwiched between layers of
seeded bread.
This challenge is right up your
street, isn't it?
You've managed to incorporate
so many different flavours in there.
Obviously textures as well.
I hope it works.
Yeah. It'll interesting.
And it's lovely the way you stick to
your Malaysian roots, I love it.
Yeah. Thank you. Thank you.
This is the sambal,
dried shrimp, onion,
chilli paste. Whoo-whoo!
And Syabira has competition in
the spicy stakes.
I like my food to be proper seasoned
like, all the flavours coming through.
I mean, it'll keep vampires away.
So Noel might not like it much.
Coated in maple bacon
and cream cheese
and filled with pulled beef brisket,
sloppy Joe sauce and spicy sirloin steak,
Sandro's three tiered smorgastarta
has been designed to meet
a particular need.
You know when you go to
a festival
and you get really, really tipsy,
you need something to bring down
the drunk,
so you go for the burger
that looks most appealing.
You go to a lot
of festivals, don't you, Prue?
I saw her at Wireless last year.
Glastonbury. In the mosh pit.
Definitely getting barbecue vibes
from you, mate.
Yeah, I mean, I am Brazilian,
after all.
It's a proper meat fest, isn't it?
All right,
Sandro, good luck, man.
Yeah, sounds interesting.
Thank you.
I would say they're doubled.
When they're happy
with their first prove...
We have black dough,
we have a white dough.
What more can you want?
...the bakers need to shape
the dough into tins...
Just knocking out the air.
He's over there. I'm trying to get
them in
the proving drawer before he gets
over here.
I'm just spreading out the filling.
...and prove it again before baking.
I'm going to make wee buns
that look like pandas.
Which personally is my favourite
part of this dish.
You know, I love a panda.
With the aid of squid ink,
James is making two-tone milk bread
and filling it with char sui pork
and plum sauce
for a Chinese panda-inspired
smorgastarta.
I have a tattoo of a panda,
first one I got,
and it was because in 2016, pandas
were made no longer endangered
so I thought that we should
celebrate them being closer
to back to normal, you know?
It's like they're going for a wee
bath, isn't it?
Pandas in a jacuzzi.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
My bread's not even in the oven yet.
It didn't rise as much as
I wanted it to,
but, hopefully, it rises more in
the second rise.
Maxy's making a plain white
and seeded wholemeal loaf
for a showstopper that's based on
a classic seafood smorgastarta
she remembers from her childhood.
I thought I'd stick to the traditional,
seeing as I was born in Sweden.
OK, so you know what you're doing.
Don't really, but, you know,
I've got an idea.
It sounds quite fresh,
the idea of the flavours seem
to balance all the way through.
It's just getting that look. Yeah.
Well, you've been having a good week
so far, so let's hope it continues.
Thank you so much. Thank you, Maxy.
I do feel extra pressure.
Everyone expects me to be able
to make a masterpiece.
Let's do this, babes.
My dough has proved - it's time
to bake.
This hand has been specially
moisturised today
so I can get that shake.
While the others start baking...
Are you joking me?
It wasn't preheating.
...Maxy risks falling behind.
That's a nightmare.
And besides a cold oven,
she faces a daunting challenge.
I'm trying to make mayonnaise
for the first time.
I've never made mayo in my life.
Mayonnaise - is that hard?
Yeah. I've only done it once before.
Why does one make mayonnaise?
Can't you just buy mayonnaise?
You get better flavour
and it shows skill as well.
So I'm going to make my own mayo.
One of those weird things that
people do.
This is a workout, oh, gosh.
You need the fats of the oil
to emulsify with
the fats of the egg yolks.
I was whisking too hard.
Janusz has made
a rather fine mayonnaise.
It's good. My first-ever mayo.
It's not rocket science, I think.
I just hope I have enough
cooling time.
Bakers, an hour and 46 minutes ago,
we should've told you you have
two hours and 46 minutes remaining.
An hour left. An hour left, yeah.
I did the maths.
So I'm looking for it
to sound hollow.
It's got a nice beat to it.
They haven't puffed up as much as
I would've liked.
If the bakers cut their bread
now, it'll tear.
It's like a game of chicken,
trying to decide when
I dare cut it.
Most are using the cooling time
to work on their decorations.
What are you doing there?
So I'm building a little person
and he'll be holding
a little fishing rod.
What are you going to call him? Rod?
Rod. I like it.
If it was a woman, you could call
her Annette.
But they're not holding a net.
Right. It's a rod.
I did my best.
Rod will sit on Kevin's two-tier
smorgastarta
which is based on his wife's
favourite fish pie recipe.
I've baked for years,
but I didn't really cook.
My wife had to teach me how to cook.
She makes a mean fish pie,
so I think it's a pretty safe bet.
Whether from the sea...
So I've got salmon and smoked haddock.
They'll go with some prawns.
...or the land...
Oh, yeah, that's ready.
...the savoury elements need
extra attention.
What are you doing now? What's this,
Tomorrow's World, what's happening?
I don't want great chunks.
Before they can fill
the baked smorgastartas...
It looks like human flesh,
to be honest.
If you had to eat someone in
the tent, who would you eat?
Matt. Matt?! Yeah. Really?!
So I can soak up all his jokes.
Wow, what about me?
Nothing? Am I the wishbone?
They're still a little bit warm,
but I think we're OK to cut it.
Thought it'd be like fleecing
a sheep.
Comes out quite nicely.
Oh, look at them pandas.
This one's missing an ear.
I don't know where it went
cos it's not in the pan.
Has anyone seen one of James's ears?
In my pocket.
Oh. Oh, no!
Feels quite close in texture
and doesn't feel very light
and fluffy.
Bakers, you've had four hours.
You're "smorganmindys" need to be
finished in half an hour.
So the first layer is the fish
filling with pepper sauce.
Going to put the eggs.
This is the plum sauce going on
and I'm going to shred some cabbage
and start layering it up.
That was close.
This is the fish pie filling.
And I need some prawns.
So I'm adding the sirloin
steak filling.
This really felt weird, I'm doing
a savoury cake.
How's this all going?
Yeah, good,
just going to put the second...
I've just realised I needed four
layers, not three.
So you've got to make
a whole layer out of...
...that.
It's like a burger, innit?
I don't have enough time, so I'm
just trying to power through.
I'm just going to spray vinegar on
chips, and now mushy peas.
My mousse is very runny,
I'm not happy with it.
So stressful about my mousse.
I tried to do it neatly.
Change of plans - I'm going to use
cream cheese,
mix with this one, add more ginger.
I'm about to pipe curry sauce
and it's turning by itself
which is pretty helpful.
It's a bit runny
so it's not covering it well
but I'm going to stick stuff on
the side to hide that.
It's going to be a milder taste of
the coconut milk
with the cream cheese.
It's a hiccups, isn't it?
How long have we got left,
if I can ask?
You have ten minutes left.
Oh, this is untidy.
Something just fell off.
We are slicing the babe in half.
My boyfriend designed it.
It's the future winner
of Great British Bake Off.
Lots of decorating.
I'm feeling quite good about it.
We'll put the good panda at the top
- he deserves pride of place.
I think this could send me home.
It's not looking too hot.
We can make it.
Trying to use a chive to make
a fishing line.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
You are kidding me.
Oh, no! His backside's fallen off.
Stay. Oh, God.
INDISTINCT
I'm so sorry for whoever has
to hoover after me.
That's very fiddly under pressure,
this bit.
Anything else I do is
going to make it look worse.
Oh, I'm just throwing things
on now.
There we go.
Your time is up.
Sure.
Please step away from
your "smorkalorkadorkens".
That was a long one.
We're a little bit older now.
Well, actually a lot older.
Oh, gosh, what a mess.
The bakers' smorgastarta will now
face the judgment of Pru and Paul.
Janusz, would you like to bring
up your smaller tortoise?
Wow!
Unbelieve-a-bubble.
To be honest, I think the idea of
fish and chips in a sandwich
is disgusting.
Wow! You've got a layer of fish,
it's on potatoes,
and a layer of mushy peas in
curry sauce flavoured icing.
Oh, my goodness, look at that.
That looks really beautiful.
Very clever fellow.
Your bread is lovely,
it's really light.
You do get fish and chips
all the way down,
including the mushy peas and the
curry sauce on the outside.
It's ingenious.
Are you still disgusted, Pru?
No.
I have to eat my words. That is
delicious. Thank you.
Thank you. Fantastic.
Well done. Fantastic.
Genius.
How very Fanny Cradock.
It's very '60s.
I think it's absolutely lovely.
Thank you. Maybe because
I practically come from the '60s.
Right. I did a white seeded bread,
the bottom layer is
a mackerel mousse with
beetroot on top. Look at that.
With another layer of avocado
and egg, and the next layer is
salmon mousse with salmon slices
and pickled cucumber.
The beetroot layers with
mackerel is lovely.
The egg and avocado needs a bit
more basic seasoning.
Salmon and pickled
cucumber's lovely.
Your bread is still a little
bit too dry. OK.
I would have gone more rye to
balance with the fish. Hmm. OK.
Thank you. Well done.
It's a bit wonky but I like the top
with the panda on it. It's clever.
Thank you.
It's milk bread that's been marbled
with squid ink,
plum sauce and char siu pork,
and pork belly done in a sweet chili sauce.
- Wow.
Your marbling worked, didn't
it? Yeah, I was quite proud of it.
I actually quite like the flavour.
It's a bit one-dimensional.
OK. It feels like the same all
the way through.
Can I just mutilate a panda?
Come on, Pru, there's not many left
as it is.
That really is nice bread.
It's lovely. Thank you.
I wondered what this was. It is
a bloke. It's a fisherman, yes.
It's crazy, Kevin.
It's clever. I mean, it's
wilted a lot around here.
I'm not sure this is
the correct choice.
Yeah, I roasted them and
I overdid it.
The fillings are fish pie
and devilled eggs,
and pickled gherkins and radishes.
I like the flavours.
The bread is slightly over-baked,
it's dry and it shouldn't be dry.
Yeah. I think it's a
little bit messy but it's amusing
and it tastes really good.
Thank you.
I must say it's certainly colourful.
I think it's a little
messy on the top.
I've got white loaf and I've got a
seeded wholemeal loaf as well.
Fillings are salmon and avocado, egg
and cress, and prawn and crayfish.
I think your three fillings
are delicious, well seasoned
and balanced, and they actually all
go together quite nicely.
The seeded one is a little bit too
heavy. The white is lovely.
But I honestly congratulate you for
trying to do two breads anyway.
It's a lovely idea. Thank you.
It looks absolutely astonishing,
it's beautifully constructed,
it's really original,
it's wonderful.
The bottom layer is
eggs with cucumber
and the middle layer is
the roasted marinated chicken.
And the top layer is the sambal
anchovy cream with peanuts.
Mm! The chicken in particular
is delicious. Isn't it?
Really delicious. It's really good
and the lightness of the cucumber
adds to that,
it balances everything out.
Terrific design, really good
flavours. Unusual.
It's lovely. Thank you.
That was amazing.
You've got a little bit of a lean.
But I'm not surprised with the
amount of meat inside this thing.
It's ridiculous.
I've got the shredded beef,
sirloin steak and I've got sloppy
Joe's in there.
The bread is baked beautifully,
it's soft, it's light.
The frosting balances well
with the inside,
because inside you've got that tang
coming from the barbecue.
You cannot identify any of the food
because the barbecue sauce
overwhelms everything.
I don't see a lot of difference
between them all,
but it really is delicious.
Thank you. Well-made though.
Yeah, thank you. Thank you.
Well done, Sandro.
Dawn, I think it really looks
lovely, it's a very simple design.
Let's hope it tastes as nice
as it looks.
Look at that.
I think the bread's good,
but some of the bread slices are
just too thick.
Yeah.
You're missing dried mint,
sesame seed, coriander,
all these key flavours that,
in Greece, is well known.
It's about identifying the flavours
and it's too bready as well. Yeah.
Bread Week has been
an embarrassment.
I think I'm at the bottom of the
pile this week. I'm quite concerned.
I'm really pleased with myself
because I took a big risk.
You know, it looks like
fish and chips.
They loved it, which I'm very happy.
The one redeeming feature was
the little cucumber man.
I'm pinning my hopes on him.
So, eight bakers. Did that make
the competition a little tougher?
Honestly I think the show stopper
had been one of the most
difficult I've judged ever.
There were some exceptional
things in that showstopper.
I think Janusz has done
exceptionally well.
But I think Syabira's
was even better.
Sort of Malaysian favours,
they were fantastic.
Sandro should be up there as well.
His pizza was excellent,
fourth in technical and the bread
was exceptional.
This morning, I was pretty sure
Carol would be leaving
because she did so badly yesterday
and I think she's saved herself.
For me, she's still in that bottom
three, along with Dawn.
That was pretty bland.
I think Kevin struggled as well.
It looked a bit of a mess.
You've got to look at Kevin,
Dawn and Carol. Because
they were all so equal, we have to
look at all their scores carefully.
Hello, bakers.
I've got the brilliant job this
week of announcing the Star Baker
and the person who is Star Baker
this week is...
...Janusz.
Thank you.
And I have the horrible job of
announcing who's going home.
And the person going home
this week is...
Well, this week,
nobody's going home.
The judges felt, given the quality
here and the fact that Rebs and
Abdul aren't here, that everybody
deserved the chance to bake again.
Thank you so much.
Hearing that you are a Star Baker,
it's a feeling out of this world.
You just cannot believe it,
that someone says,
"No, you're the one this week."
Janusz is very artistic.
Almost illusion in some
of his bakes.
He's clever and he's certainly one
to watch going forward.
Wow.
I dodged a bullet.
So relieved. That was like
squeaky bum time.
For the next few days
I just want to sleep but no,
it's practice every day.
I've got my online shopping coming
tomorrow, I'm going
to be on the ball.
They were all thrilled to bits
because nobody had to go,
they're all friends, they don't
want to see their friends go,
but sooner or later we have
to send two bakers home
and that's not nice.
Next time...
Cheat. We have a cheat in the tent.
...it's back to full strength for a
Bake Off first... It's Mexican week.
...and the bakers are confronted with
a yeasty signature...
Like a generous portion, I do.
...a meaty technical...
Like a mad professor, I am flinging
things into a bowl.
...and a teetering, towering
dairy-soaked showstopper.
Why is it so bulged to this side?
Oh, my goodness, I'm going to cry.
Who will win out in the ultimate
Mexican stand-off...
Oh, my God.
...and whose time in the tent is up?
Looks like you sat on them.
Now I'm in panic mode.
Are you a Star Baker in the making?
If you'd like to apply for the next
series of Bake Off, visit...